moment one day I I don't remember what
it was but I called my mom so but my dad
he goes oh would you say to your mother
and I was like I was like oh I called
her and he goes why did you say that I
was like because she was acting like and
then he goes yeah he goes yeah and then
he just punched me in the face like out
of nowhere like like this fist like like
she was 14 like punch me in the face
yeah uh hit me like in the cheek like
Point like where I like fell into the
wall stunned like did not ever in a
million years but my heart was like I'm
sure he grabbed me and he gave I knew he
gave me like a kiss on the forehead he
goes here's the thing he goes I'm sorry
I had to do that he goes but you call a
woman and you think you're a man he goes
being punched in the face that's what
happens to men if they call a woman they
get punched in the face he goes are you
a man and I was like oh
I'm not a man it goes in a real man
would never call a woman because she
apologized to your mother put some ice
in your cheek you're gonna be fine he
goes don't ever make me have to do that
again